selon un récent sondage 74 % des
Français considèrent qu'il y a trop
d'immigrés en France et oui en 2022 7
million d'immigrés vivait dans notre
pays soit 10,3 % de la population
française sur
134280 obligation de quitter le
territoire français prononcé l'an
dernier 9164 seulement ont été exécutés
soit un peu moins de 7 %. alors que font
les 93 % qui ne respectent pas cette
obligation il reste et chaque année il
s'accumule et on ne compte plus les
situations où les expulsions de
impossible comme ce fut le cas de
Mohamed mogoukov l'assassin de Dominique
Bernard nous ne sommes plus maîtrre de
l'avenir de notre pays alors que faire
en matière de lutte contre l'immigration
29 lois ont été voté en 40 ans ce qui
fait plus d'une loi tous les 2 ans pour
quel résultat plus il y a de lois plus
il y a d'immigration et plus il y a
d'immigration plus il y a de loi à quoi
donc servirait une anème loi sur
l'immigration comme le voudrait le
gouvernement une seule solution demeure
et elle est simple modifier la
Constitution par un référendum ce qui
permettrait un de limiter chaque année
par un vote au Parlement le nombre
d'étrangers accueillis en France sans
qu'aucune jurisprudence fondée sur des
traités ou des conventions
internationales ne puissent s'y opposer
2 de faciliter les expulsions des
étrangers en situation irrégulière et se
menaçant l'ordre public 3 de mettre un
terme aux dérives de l'asile en
instruisant les demandes à l'extérieur
de nos frontières jamais sous la 5e
République le peuple français n'a été
consulté en matière d'immigration il est
grand temps de le faire alors si vous en
avez assez de l'immigration à contrôler
signez cette pétition pour demander un
référendum
[Musique]